I invite François Astorg,
mother of the city of Annecy, to join me
[Applause]
Mr. Prefect
Mr. Consul of Portugal Ladies
and Gentlemen, elected officials and
parliamentarians,
Ladies and Gentlemen, representatives
of the civil and military authorities,
of  emergency services
Ladies and Gentlemen, representatives
of associations dear to the sky, dear
friends, hello to all,
before I begin, I would like to thank
each of you for your presence
today, some have
traveled from far away, it is  a strong sign
of union and solidarity that of
us all being together here for a
citizen gathering,
thank you to all those who have shown us
their support, their sympathy and their
friendship in recent days,
thank you to my team for the organization
without delay  to gather and to
Citya for having made this place available to us
and for having given us its
precious help
this June 8
in the very place where I am talking to you about these
products an event which will forever mark
the life of our city
of children in  young people and adults
were attacked in a playground
by an individual armed with a knife
and we two years old
Alba 2 years old
Peter
22 months
but also Youssouf 78 years old and Manuel 72
years old
remain to this day hospitalized in Grenoble in
Annecy in  Geneva and it is first of all in their
name that we are gathered here at this
moment
we are hanging on the hope that he
will recover and leave
the hospital as quickly as possible to return to a
normal life
my first thoughts are therefore  for them
for their family and for their loved ones
thus we have just experienced a tragedy which has
affected our city our country and the
whole world
because with the wounds of ethy Peter and
Manuel it is the United Kingdoms the
Netherlands and Portugal which are
today in pain
the authorities of each of these countries were
able to be among us today and I
know that she regrets it
thank you for your
if I address you as the mother
of our city I come too
speaking to you as a father of a family as a
human being who, just like you,
is horrified and bruised by this
attack
your concern I feel it I
share it
Annecy is today a family and
when we touch the members of a
family  all the others are impacted touched
be gathered here in this place in the
heart
of Annecy in a haven of peace and
authentic freedom where we come to
breathe have fun enjoy the lake
share moments of conviviality yes
this place that an unspeakable act to
transforming this place into a scene of terror
allows us today to demonstrate
true solidarity
there is no other choice than to
respond with unity through communion and
hope these words  we must
make them live, defend them at all costs,
be united in these difficult moments, in
these moments of unspeakable pain and
tragedy, it is about choosing
the future against that of
destruction, it is about building rather than hating.
I am convinced that
human solidarity when it is exercised when it
is expressed becomes limitless
warn the courage of Henri
that of Lilian
but also of the municipal agents Georges
and Yassine and all those who acted with
heroism the
proof is the blood  coldness of the
police officers and their rapid intervention
allowing the salient
proof to be neutralized is still the response provided
by the emergency services, civil security in
the helicopter landed to help
evacuate the victims and the
remarkable responsiveness of the medical staff
proof  is the collective action of the
public authorities with this
determination has saved and protected our
fellow citizens
thank you all for being there this morning
alongside the city
the prefecture the municipal police
of Annecy the national police the
gendarmerie the 27th BCA the  SAMU the
Red Cross civil security
finally return our presence here
with each
other to overcome the pain
we are together we will face
together
I am well aware of this in the face of such
horror words can seem
powerless in the
face of such  such pain the words
can seem too weak
we are always helpless in the face of
cruelty and barbarity
how to respond to this
how to put the right words on an
event which is slowly overtaking a
behavior which despises the foundations
of human reason
how to speak of  an act which falls
outside of all humanity against the
most basic values ​​which
allow us to live together to
respect others to accept others
empathy and courage at the time when I am
speaking to you where  I am speaking to you forms the
first barrier against human madness
without taking children
to try to their physical integrity it is
obviously what is most cowardly
it is attacking the innocence of the most
vulnerable of  between us to those of
society to those that society must
protect with all its strength
because the child has sacred itself
childhood symbolizes the future the
possible future filiation and transmission
it represents life and even more
'is the poetry of life
it is all this which has been attacked here I
say last by this act yes it is
the whole of the human community which
has been stabbed
but there is another duty that of
refusing to  a block despair hatred
the ease of certain speeches we
must not give in to the temptation of
distrust of the fear of another form of
buying it intellectual
on the contrary we must look ahead to
show ourselves worthy and even stronger
in the  the ordeal that we must face
I allow myself to insist in this
children's play park on the lot of other
children will come
and life will sing again with its
children's laughter life will regain its
rights if the whole world is  at the bedside
of Annecy at this very moment at this
very moment Annecy will rise again
to finish I would like to quote you
this sentence from the writer Georges
Bernanos
hope and the greatest and most
difficult victory that a man can
win over his  soul
hope is a risk to run
when we go until the end of the night we
meet another Aurora
dear friends
talk to you about this and tell you that I
am with you that you can count
on me and on the elected officials of our  city
from the bottom of my heart I thank you for being
present today thank you
thank you Mr. Mayor for these
truly sincere and touching words
since we are talking about life as you so
well recalled in your
speech
I will invite you to join me now
then Pautex citizen an escienne who will
interpret for us a song of hope
speak to me about love by Lucienne Boyer
sublimated by a musical instrument in the
shower melody is known to all our
cherubs
then now I let you sow
love by making  turn your music box
[Applause]
[Music]
me things too
much
[Music] [
Music]
always
to stay at home supreme
we love you
[Music]
his life although deep down I don't
believe any of it but nevertheless I  I still want to
listen to what I adore your voice or its
caressing
whispers that it is
quivering pour me of its beautiful story
and despite myself I want to believe in it
[Applause]
[Music]
of love
tell me again tender things
your beautiful
speech my heart is not there to
hear it
for
8 a.m. always
you repeat
[Music]
supreme
we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Laure for this moving
performance
as Mr. Mayor reminds us,
solidarity and universality are the
values ​​which carry us today
for the rest of this ceremony
I invite to join me on stage
all the elected officials of the municipal council
of the city of Annecy and the artists
Aria Gallaz and roré peralt de los
cayaditos
[Applause]
in  sign of union and fraternity two
artists from far away hosted
today within the collective
of artists anetien art by friend we create
a unique strawberry for the city of Annecy
this canvas is today a symbol of
peace and  hope
when years of his English people
Dutch people Portuguese are affected
it is everyone who is in turmoil
these characters in the fresco
touch us with their depth and the hope
they evoke to change the world
thank you
ariagallaz and  Roret Peralta de los
cayaditos we can applaud them
thank you
ladies gentlemen
for ending with kindness this
time of gathering of sharing and
fraternity many meanings are
hidden behind 5 syllables known
throughout the world with extraordinary power
that of Mount thank you
in the name of the city of  'Annecy we
warmly thank all the
municipal services of the city the
technical teams of Citya the
state services the associations and
partners who worked directly or
indirectly in the smooth running of this
ceremony this morning and there are many
thanks to  you thank you for them take care
of yourself
life is beautiful we wish you
a pleasant day
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Applause]